le prix de l'arc de triomphe c'est l'un
des événements incontournables de la
saison hippique cette course de prestige
est suivi par des milliers de
spectateurs c'est toujours un événement
qui rassemble turfistes est belle
élégante ambiance avec parce qu'elles
sont et eric mangini longchamp c'est
super côté pelouse d'accès gratuit on
peut boire pique-niqué imaginez les
dernières combinaison que personne à
combiner et qui sont forcément gagnante
le tout en attendant sagement la course
d course ça nous fait une bonne journée
à penser car il y avait aussi un peu de
spectacle
c'est un des plus grands prix du monde
actuellement
longchamp c'est chic coûté tribu côté
dames et messieurs à chapeau
c'est loin drapeau
pourtant côté pelouse c'est
impressionnant défilé de couvre chef
laisse indifférent c'est simple je ne
vois pas avec un chapeau
quand la course approche il n'y a plus
de chapeau qui tiennent la fièvre monte
dans toutes les têtes
ce sont les derniers paris quel est
votre favori numéro un
e
voilà c'est
les fonds
et puis voici l'homme dont le nom est
sur toutes les lèvres il s'appelle
yutaka ptac et il vient du japon où une
est une idole avec son cheval white
mausole il figure parmi les favoris
la course est lancée 2400 mètres de
suspense est au bout deux jumelles le
triomphe d'un irlandais carnegie monté
par un français thierry jarnet la
conclusion d'un grand connaisseur de la
chose hippiques l'avait gardée par
l'église comme avait su tout le monde
mais je crois que la misère la beauté la
force de carnets guy nouvelle
illustration d'un vieux proverbe on ne
gagne pas l'arc de triomphe avec un ami